Matthew Fox was on a major career role
for two decades he headlined not one but
two popular shows in a row with six
season the family drama party of five
and then six more years on the sci-fi
mystery phenomenon lost not long after
as a result of this pair of beloved
series he had the rare distinction of
being both a heartthrob and the guy's
guy and seemed poised to launch from its
wild island adventures straight into the
big time but the 2010s haven't been two
kinds of Fox
despite some notable big-screen efforts
on his part here are a few theories I'll
explain why lately Matthew Fox has
seemed so he broke big on TV
Fox established himself as a television
star thanks to his turns as Charlie
Salinger and Jack Shepard the small
screen was his home from the get-go
having just a few film credits to his
name by the time lost catapulted him
into the spotlight but the silver screen
still piqued his interest and he tried
out supporting roles in movies like
smoking aces and We Are Marshall neither
of those were massive hits but they did
suggest that there might be a place for
him in the movie biz unfortunately a
controversial show ending can follow an
actor around like a dark cloud and a few
people would argue that last finale was
perhaps the worst show ending of all
time it wasn't Fox's fault of the series
ended on such a confusing and
frustrating note but as the face of the
series there's a chance the blame could
have fallen on him a little third at
least where ticket buyers were concerned
with audiences as upset as they were
about the series crazy conclusion
there's a very real chance that some Fox
fatigue sets in as part of the fallout
hey maybe the smoke monster will have
better luck big screen bombs
he may have proven that he can handle
himself on a film set with his smaller
outings but it should be blockbuster
debut Speed Racer was a car wreck it had
a bloated budget and a lot of
expectations behind it but critics hated
it and they lost a ton of money at the
box office its big-screen Korea had no
hatch hideaway to shelter from this box
office form the good news for fox's that
he was never really held accountable for
the film's poor performance but the
wheels were already rolling in the wrong
direction
then Alex cross happened past
adaptations of James Patterson's Alex
Cross novels have done fairly well
movies like kiss the girls and along
came a spider but Alex Cross failed to
live up to his predecessors despite some
serious effort on Fox's part in the film
Fox played super bad guy Picasso who
tortured and maimed people for sports
the actor reportedly dropped a whopping
20% of his weight to play the villain
and shed his former image as a heroic
jack from lust but despite how
convincingly he played for caso the
movie was absolutely trashed by critics
and even worse ignored by audiences how
much cutting room floor folks got one
more shot in a film that actually did
really well at the box office
too bad that his role was chopped for
the point that no one knew he was
actually in it the adaptation of Max
Brooks is on the epic World War Z was
supposed to be something else than what
audiences saw in theaters but after the
original cut was shot a large chunk of
the script was rewritten and we shot
that left most of Fox's seams on the
editing room floor Fox would have
starred as a colleague of Brad Pitt
Jerry Layne carrying four lanes family
while he's off globe-trotting in an
effort to stifle the undead epidemic but
his role became a blink a dismissive
power jump a scene seriously that was
their hope he didn't blink all the wrong
headlines in August 2011 fox's name was
dragged through the mud as he was
accused by a Cleveland woman of punching
her in the arms right leg thighs and
chest later his former lost co-star
Dominic Monaghan claimed on Twitter in
2012 that he beats women as a reference
to that event the woman's suit was
ultimately dropped and Fox strongly
denied the claims but his reputation was
already sullied Fox denied the
allegations completely in an interview
of Ellen but it's hard to undo damage
like that once it's been done Fox may
have maintained his innocence of the
assault charges he faced but in 2012 he
was guilty of an entirely different
crime he was arrested for driving under
the influence in his home state of
Oregon he did fess up to that incident
on Ellen insisting that he learned a
hard lesson and that he'd never do that
again
even so the combination of these tabloid
frenzied incidents certainly didn't help
to elevate his public profile break from
Hollywood even before things started to
slow down for Fox's professional life it
all
been considering stepping away from the
spotlight for a while
instead of living in Los Angeles like so
many other stars he lives in Oregon
where he likes to fly planes and hang
out with his family he told Men's
Fitness in 2012 that he was considering
retiring from the industry even then
saying that if he didn't get quality
opportunities it probably stepped away
from the scene seems like he had a
contingency plan in place the whole time
but for Fox fans hoping to see more of
the actor the good news is that he
hasn't altogether disappeared from the
entertainment industry in 2015 he
appeared in a pair of little scene
horror pics extinction and bone tomahawk
the latter of which was very well
received by critics if not by audiences
so it seems he's not completely done
with movies and television just yet in
the meantime we can watch endless lost
reruns and tried to make heads or tails
of what was actually happening on that
dumb island
it's the mystery that keeps on giving
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff you
know your love to
[Music]